Russia promises to respond harshly to an
unprecedented international rebuke more
than 20 countries announced yesterday
they are expelling Russian diplomats the
u.s. ordered 60 Russians to leave and
will close the Russian consulate in
Seattle the coordinated action is in
response to Russia's alleged use of an
urge nerve agent to poison former spy
ser Gary Paul and his daughter in
Britain Charlie d'Agata is in Moscow
with Russia's reaction charlie good
morning good morning in addition to
expulsion the Russians are considering
which US consulate sit closed here
that's after the Trump administration
shut down
Russia's consulate in Seattle blaming
diplomats there of being intelligence
officers so close to the u.s. naval base
and Boeing headquarters it's fast
becoming the most serious diplomatic
crisis since the Cold War unprecedented
numbers and an unexpectedly hard line
from a trump administration that's been
reluctant to square off against
President Vladimir Putin a show of
solidarity for Britain after the
assassination attempt of former double
agent Sergei scruple and his daughter in
Salisbury England three weeks ago
retaliation for what British Foreign
Secretary Boris Johnson called an
unacceptable pattern of behavior from
Russia it manifests itself across the
globe from Syria to to Salisbury and
people a statement seen as retribution
for a litany of Russian transgressions
against the West annexing Crimea the
ongoing military conflict with Ukraine
suspected meddling in foreign elections
president Putin's boasts of new nuclear
weapons capable of striking the u.s.
former US ambassador to Russia bill
burns says president Trump's tougher
stance signals a major shift in tactics
it seems to me it's the end of an
illusion
in a sense the illusion under which
President Trump seems to have operated
for a while the illusion that you could
do some kind of a grand bargain with
Putin's Russia this morning Russian
Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov condemned
the
expulsion is a small group of countries
giving in to blackmail
that's the Washington's tools and
instruments of work this morning foreign
minister Lavrov said there should be no
doubt that Russia will respond saying no
one would put up with such thuggish
behavior and Russia certainly won't Gail
thank you very much Charlie d'Agata
reporting from Moscow